debatte über corona bonds die
eu-finanzminister suchen nach lösungen
um den wirtschaftlichen kollaps
abzuwenden britischer premier im
krankenhaus wegen seiner corona
infektion wird boris johnson auf der
intensivstation behandelt und lufthansa
zieht notbremse das unternehmen stellt
den betrieb von germanwings ein und
macht sich langfristig auf viel weniger
passagiere gefasst
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesen dienstag schön dass sie dabei
sind die korona krise stellt alle auf
eine probe auch die eben wie besteht sie
diesen härtetest und wie kann sie
besonders betroffenen mitgliedstaaten
unterstützen
darüber gibt es heftigen streit ende
märz konnten sich die staats und
regierungschefs nicht auf gemeinsame
hilfen einigen
heute sollten die finanzminister neue
vorschläge machen
besonders umstritten sind die
sogenannten corona bonds also gemeinsame
schulden der eu staaten die einen wollen
sie unbedingt die anderen auf keinen
fall
mögliche alternative ein etwa 500
milliarden euro schweres programm mit
einem eu kurzarbeitergeld und krediten
von der europäischen investitionsbank
und dem euro-rettungsfonds stefan
leifert die details die mahnung dass
europa die zukunft ist werden die
finanzminister heute wieder nicht lesen
wieder treffen sie sich nicht in
brüssels europaviertel sondern per
videochat um eine antwort auf die
drohende wirtschaftskatastrophe zu
finden
es geht um ein milliardenprogramm mit
krediten aus dem euro-rettungsfonds esm
dessen bedingungen gelockert würden um
gelder der europäischen investitionsbank
die speziell firmen stützen sollen und
um ein kurzarbeitergeld der eu
kommission maßnahmen im wert einer
halben billion euro
drei instrumente der solidarität der
gemeinsamen organisationen der
bewältigung der krise und deshalb auch
ganz notwendige und richtige
entscheidung ich hoffe sehr dass wir das
heute zustande bringen auch wenn es
natürlich eine große aufgabe ist wenn 19
euro länder zusammen diskutieren
denn seit tagen führt berlin eine
abwehrschlacht gegen korona bonds
gemeinsame schuldenaufnahme die europas
süden sich so wünscht die wirtschaftlich
schwächeren und verschuldeten länder
südeuropas müssen wenn sie kredite
aufnehmen
hohe zinsen zahlen wenn alle
europäischen länder gemeinsame anleihen
sogenannten eurobonds herausgeben würden
die zinsen für die südeuropäer sinken
weil die wirtschaftlich starken
nordeuropäer für sie bürgen und auch
würden wir sagen nein zum esm zu
eurobonds aber ganz klar ja der esm ist
ein instrument und das haben wir immer
gesagt dass absolut unangemessen ist
eurobonds sind die lösung und eine
ernsthafte und effektive antwort auf die
notlage die wir erwarten
deutschlands schwimmer doch im geld
schallte es aus europas süden berlin
bleibt hart weiß aber auch dass es
diesmal nicht nur um geld sondern auch
um viel vertrauen geht aus brüssel und
rom sind unsere korrespondenten
zugeschaltet zuerst zu stefan leifert
die frustration vor allem bei italienern
und spanien ist immens was steht auf dem
spiel
ja so viel dass sich die eu ein
scheitern eigentlich nicht leisten kann
denn dann stünde sie in ihrer schwersten
phase der geschichte als heillos
zerstritten und völlig unsolidarisch da
wenn die südländer im laufe dieser
sitzung die jetzt seit drei stunden
läuft weiterhin darauf beharren dass sie
am gesamt paket nur zustimmen wenn darin
irgendwie auch euro oder corona bronze
enthalten sind dann wird eine einigung
schwierig aber es gibt zwei kompromiss
möglichkeiten die eine möglichkeit wäre
dass man sich auf ein instrument einigt
was vom system her den eurobonds nahe
kommt aber nicht so heißt und an strenge
auflagen geknüpft wäre das ist er nicht
so wahrscheinlichere fall
die zweite möglichkeit und das ist der
wahrscheinlichere fall ist dass man das
schwierige thema corona bonds
ausklammert und heute sich erstmal nur
auf das ei nicht worin schon konsens
besteht und das ist eine ganze menge
die sitzung läuft jetzt hier seit
inzwischen über drei stunden eine
einigung ist nicht in sicht aber in
einem bleibt sich die eu treu in ihrer
schwersten phase streitet sie über die
alten konflikte nachfrage an andreas
postel in rom erklären sie es uns warum
lehnen die italiener kredite aus dem
euro-rettungsfonds esm ab und wollen
stattdessen unbedingt corona bombs
italiens premierminister giuseppe konnte
hat den esm bislang immer sehr deutlich
abgelehnt dafür hat er zwei gründe
angeführt erstens hätten die esm kredite
zu kurze laufzeiten um die märkte
wirklich zu beruhigen und
das zweite gegenargument ist ein
innenpolitisches denn der esm ist seit
der euro-krise mit dem makel behaftet
gemachte fehler müssten korrigiert
werden doch das weiß italien in der
korona krise weit von sich
in den so genannten corona bonds dagegen
sieht italien kraftvolle zeichen um auch
die anti europäer im eigenen land in
schach zu halten
die italiener haben sich zu beginn der
korona krise im stich gelassen gefühlt
von europa und auch von deutschland auch
wenn es mittlerweile zahlreiche
beispiele für unterstützung gibt ist die
sorge doch groß dass die
rechtspopulisten das salvini und co
zulauf bekommen wenn es jetzt keine
kraftvollen zeichen gemeinsamer
europäischer solidarität mit den
gründungsmitgliedern italien gibt denn
so das signal hier aus rom scheitert
italien so scheitert europa schwere
zeiten für eu dankeschön an die kollegen
hinrunden brüssel
andreas postel und stefan leifert
eurobonds ja oder nein darum geht es
auch in einem zdf spezial um 19.25
direkt nach uns und welche länder welche
corona hilfen fordern all das haben wir
nochmal zum nachlesen online in unsere
zdf heute hierzulande warnt
gesundheitsminister sparen davor
sinkende infektionszahlen als zeichen
der entspannung zu werten
wir dürfen uns nicht in falscher
sicherheit wiegen sagt er
thomas konsum hat die aktuellen zahlen
infektionen und gibt es immer mehr und
wohl auch lichtblicke
laut johns hopkins universität sind in
deutschland stand 18 uhr 30 mehr als
105.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt 1854 sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
aber auch diese zahl steigt mehr als
36.000 sind als genesen erfasst damit
sind seit gestern mehr menschen gesund
geworden als menschen sich neu infiziert
haben und auch diese entwicklung weckt
hoffnung anfang märz hat sich die zahl
der erkrankten noch alle zwei tage
verdoppelt nun sind es 12,2 tage die
ausbreitung wird also langsamer aber
erst bei einer verdopplung zeit von etwa
14 tagen könnten die beschränkungen im
alltag gelockert werden
wann es so weit sein könnte dazu müssen
die experten noch mehr wissen helfen
sollen digitale fitness armbänder und
smart uhren die erfassen etwa puls und
körpertemperatur also auch kurve
symptome wie abgeschlagenheit und fieber
eine neue app überträgt die daten ans
robert koch institut die nutzung
freiwillig und anonym wir wünschen uns
dass sie viele menschen diese corinna
daten spende app herunterladen und
mitmachen
dann können unsere wissenschaftler
daraus zusätzlich rückschlüsse über die
verbreitung von kogit 19 10
vor allem können sie genauer erfassen wo
viele infektionen sind wo man also
stärker handeln muss kurz wo man
wirklich von lichtblicken sprechen kann
auf corona getestet wird derzeit nur bei
verdacht das heißt niemand weiß genau
wie viele menschen sich infiziert haben
ohne es zu merken
also wie verbreitet das virus
tatsächlich ist um solche fragen zu
klären wird in münchen nun in 3000
haushalten den bewohnern unter anderem
blut abgenommen
für eine studie zur verwaltung des
corona virus cornelia strauß hat die
details inwieweit hat sich coop 19 in
der bevölkerung verbreitet dieser frage
gehen mitarbeiter des tropeninstituts
der ludwig maximilian universität und
des helmholtz zentrums in münchen nach
in 3000 haushalten die nach einem
zufallsprinzip ausgewählt werden
unterziehen sich die bewohner
verschiedenen tests ziel der studie ist
der politik bei der entscheidung helfen
zu können welche maßnahmen weiterhin
notwendig sind wir können natürlich
nicht erlauben dass wir jetzt irgendwie
100.000 neue infektionen pro tag
bekommen müssen uns auf einem gewissen
niveau einpendeln damit wir auch durch
die erhoffte herdenimmunität am ende
eine relativ rasche infektionen durch
alle bevölkerungsschichten danach
erreichen vielleicht ausgenommen den
eltern erkranken
ein jahr lang werden rund 4500 münchner
regelmäßig untersucht so wird auch der
frage nachgegangen wer möglicherweise
mit dem virus kontakt hatte ohne es zu
merken
diese frage beschäftigt auch viele
bürger wird zufällig für die studie
ausgewählt wurde freut sich auch deshalb
daran teilnehmen zu können
gleichzeitig weiß man sich eventuell zu
der kugel gehört die forscher aus
münchen stehen in engem kontakt mit
ihren kollegen im ganzen land sie hoffen
in wenigen wochen von ersten ergebnissen
berichten zu können
die grosse frage bleibt wann haben die
beschränkungen ein ende
mehrere ministerpräsidenten haben heute
wieder appelliert geduld zu haben
ungeduld gefährde leben sagte bayerns
regierungschef söder und auch vom
ethikrat dem beratungsgremium der
bundesregierung hieß es heute ja es sei
zu früh für lockerungen aber es müsse
darüber geredet werden wie lange ein
solcher zustand der gesellschaft
zuzumuten ist bernd benthin berichtet
debattieren statt einfach nur
durchhalten der ethikrat fordert einen
offenen meinungsstreit über den ausstieg
aus den corona maßnahmen
es ist zu früh öffnungen jetzt
vorzunehmen
aber es ist nie zu früh über kriterien
für öffnungen nachzudenken
alles andere wäre ein
obrigkeitsstaatliches denken dass bei
uns nicht verfangen sollte und mit dem
man das so notwendige vertrauen der
bevölkerung nicht stärken würde öffnungs
perspektiven seien wichtig für die
motivation meint der ethikrat man könne
da noch nichts in aussicht stellen meint
die regierung wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass das was wir tun verantwortbar ist
und das bedeutet am tag nach ostern
osterdienstag werden wir bewerten und
dann werden wir über vorschläge
diskutieren wie es weitergeht oberste
priorität hätte der gesundheitsschutz so
die kanzlerin gestern der ethikrat aber
wirbt für eine stärkere betrachtung
aller krisen kosten der blick auf die
notwendigkeit den an cupid 19 erkranken
zu helfen verleitet bisweilen dazu die
opfer des logins aus dem blick zu
verlieren
es ist ja nicht nur die wirtschaft die
unsere lebensgrundlage sichert die auf
dem spiel steht wenn wir den lock down
so fortführen vereinsamung existenzangst
auch das geld ist zu berücksichtigen und
noch einen krisen grundsatz der
regierung stellt der ethikrat in frage
er ist lockern und dann wieder anziehen
das muss er nicht falsch sein
wir können dinge auch tastend machen wir
können auch maßnahmen wieder
zurücknehmen dass es kein versagen von
politik wenn eine maßnahme sich als
nicht irgendwie erfolgreich erwiesen hat
dann das zu erkennen und zu sagen wir
nehmen sie zurück gerade jetzt so meint
der ethikrat braucht es einen offenen
wettbewerb der ideen und perspektiven
die hoffnung machen
die virus krise wird auch immer mehr zur
wirtschaftskrise besonders heftig trifft
es die luftfahrtbranche
der lufthansa konzern will jetzt den
flugbetrieb seiner tochter germanwings
komplett einstellen außerdem soll die
lufthansa flotte deutlich verkleinert
werden 18 langstrecken und elf
mittelstreckenjets bleiben dauerhaft am
boden darunter mehrere flieger vom typ
a380
das erklärte die airline vor zwei
stunden
dominik löschmeister am frankfurter
flughafen wie steht es um europas größte
fluglinie wird die lufthansa bald
staatliche hilfe brauchen ja die
lufthansa hat ja selbst gesagt dass sie
mit den staatlichen stellen spricht auch
mit dem wirtschaftsministerium
es wird da in erster linie um kredite
gehen um absicherungen über die kfw
sicherlich nicht direkt um eine
staatsbeteiligung dafür hat die
lufthansa eigentlich noch genügend
liquidität etwa 4 milliarden euro
aber wenn diese krise von corona und
auch die auswirkungen andauern dann ist
steht das sicherlich auch als eine
option dar was klar ist der lufthansa
vorstand hat zwei dinge heute
beschlossen die germanwings wird
stillgelegt das ist eine airline die
bisher nur noch 30 flugzeuge hatte 1400
mitarbeiter die vor allem für euro wings
geflogen wird und im zweiten paket
werden flugzeuge stillgelegt darunter
sechs maschinen vom typ a380
das wird vorgezogen die sollten 22 2022
stillgelegt werden das wird vorgezogen
hinzu kommen weitere maschinen und das
ist einfach ein signal dass die
lufthansa doch in einem schwierigen
fahrwasser jetzt ist in dieser krise man
erwartet dass die reisenden und vor
allen dingen auch die urlauber so
schnell nicht zurückkehren wenn corona
auch überstanden ist
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
frankfurt dominik löschmeister die
folgen der korona krise treffen uns alle
besonders hart ist es aber für menschen
die auf hilfe angewiesen sind hilfe
dieses jetzt einfach nicht mehr gibt
in deutschland sind mehr als dreieinhalb
millionen menschen pflegebedürftig gut
zweieinhalb millionen davon werden zu
hause betreut
oft unterstützt durch osteuropäische
pflegekräfte die dürfen aber nicht mehr
einreisen
wanka heise berichtet theresa radomsko
aus polen pflegt seit drei monaten den
84 jährigen hermann rund um die uhr nach
einem schlaganfall ist er halbseitig
gelähmt nach drei monaten muss theresa
aus arbeitsrechtlichen gründen für ein
paar wochen zurück nach polen
deswegen braucht der 84-jährige eine
neue hilfskraft
doch an der deutsch polnischen grenze
herrschen zurzeit erschwerte
einreisebedingungen deswegen machen sich
die schätzungsweise bis zu 300.000
familien mit pflegebedürftigen
angehörigen sorgen dass bald keine
betreuungskräfte mehr einreisen können
müsste dann ihren job aufgeben um sich
um ihren vater zu kümmern
das bedeutet allerdings dass ich dann
kein gehalt bekommen
und das ist natürlich auch nicht so
einfach
monatelang ohne gehalt das pflege
unternehmen das bisher die betreuerin in
die familie vermittelt hat fordert
aufgrund der verschärften situation
politische entscheidungen dass diese
betreuungskräfte als systemrelevant
anerkannt werden das heißt dass ihnen
auch wirklich die möglichkeit weiter
offen bleibt dass sie nach deutschland
einreisen können hier würde ich mir
wünschen dass die bundesregierung
regelung trifft mit diesen ländern das
besonders diese berufsgruppe weiter
reisen darf de hat für die kommenden
wochen doch noch eine betreuerin aus
polen bekommen wie es danach weitergeht
und ob theresa wiederkommen darf weiß
sie nicht und jetzt nach großbritannien
wo der premierminister auf die
intensivstation verlegt werden musste
boris johnson ist mit dem corona virus
infiziert und wird seit vorgestern abend
im krankenhaus st thomas in london
behandelt sein zustand hat er sich
offenbar verschlechtert die
amtsgeschäfte musste er an seinen
außenminister dominik raab übergeben
diana zimmermann in london wie geht es
dem premierminister
der außenminister hat soeben erklärt
dass er zuversichtlich sei dass boris
johnson seine erkrankung gut überstehen
werde
er habe keine lungenentzündung und
müssen nicht künstlich beatmet werden
das klingt vielversprechend allerdings
hat die regierung in den vergangenen
tagen die erkrankung des presse premiers
massiv herunter gespielt dass china noch
putzmunter
während er de facto schon auf dem weg in
die intensivstation war das hat man
natürlich getan um weitere unsicherheit
zu vermeiden in dem britischen system
hat der premierminister eine zentrale
rolle
es gibt nicht mal einen wirklichen
erklärten stellvertreter für ihn
außerdem hat das land massive probleme
die krankenhäuser melden weiter einen
mangel an personal und material
die heutigen todeszahlen sind
erschreckend 786 menschen sind in den
vergangenen 24 stunden hier gestorben
die situation ist alles andere als unter
kontrolle und er wirkt natürlich ein
schwerkranker premier auf der
intensivstation handlungsunfähig für
ausgesprochen beunruhigend
danke nochmal an die hand was tun mit
und gegen korona da gibt es in europa
verschiedene strategien nach österreich
haben weitere länder angekündigt ihre
maßnahmen zu lockern dänemark etwa will
am 15 april kindergärten und die ersten
fünf jahrgangsstufen der schulen wieder
öffnen und in tschechien ist seit heute
so genannte individualsport im freien
wieder erlaubt etwa joggen tennis und
golf aber die hygiene regeln für den
einzelhandel werden verschärft
noch strenger sind die verantwortlichen
in paris dort ist ab sofort sport im
freien tagsüber von 10 bis 19 uhr
verboten
in zeiten von corona beobachtet die
bundesregierung einen wachsenden
antisemitismus im land in krisen seien
die menschen besonders anfällig für
kruden erklärungsversuche sagte der
antisemitismus beauftragte felix klein
so heißt es zum beispiel in sozialen
medien israel habe das corona virus als
biowaffe entwickelt bildungsministerin
carlitscheck kündigte ein
forschungsprogramm an ursachen und
verbreitung von antisemitismus müssten
stärker untersucht
werden in polen soll der neue präsident
am 10 mai ausschließlich per brief
gewählt werden das hat die regierende
partei gestern abend im parlament
durchgesetzt
ihr kandidat der amtierende präsident
nun da liegt in umfragen vorn
angesichts der wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen der chor ohne krise könnte
sich das allerdings ändern sollte die
wahl verschoben werden
genau das hatte die opposition gefordert
sie sieht derzeit keine chance wahlkampf
zu machen
jenseits von corona dann heute noch
diese wichtige meldung in der nächsten
woche will deutschland nach
zdf-informationen 50 unbegleitete
flüchtlingskinder von den griechischen
inseln aufnehmen
nach ihrer ankunft kommen die
minderjährigen zunächst 14 tage in
quarantäne und sollen dann auf
verschiedene bundesländer verteilt
werden
das ganze soll morgen im bundeskabinett
beschlossen werden und wie es heißt ein
erster schritt sein überraschender
freispruch in australien kardinal george
pell saß bereits ein jahr wegen
kindesmissbrauchs in haft nun hat das
oberste gericht des landes das urteil
gekippt bereits kurze zeit später
verließ der 78 jährige das gefängnis die
richter sahen begründete zweifel an
seiner schuld
hell war vorgeworfen worden ende der
90er jahre zwei chorknaben missbraucht
zu haben
2009 10 wurde er deshalb zu sechs jahren
haft verurteilt waren die fußball
weltmeisterschaften 2018 und 2022
gekauft den verdacht gibt es schon
länger jetzt der vorwurf schwarz auf
weiß in einer erweiterten anklageschrift
zum fifa prozess in den usa russland und
katar haben bestochen heißt es da die
beiden länder hatten bei einer doppel
vergabe den zuschlag bekommen nun soll
es klare beweise für stimmenkäufe geben
beobachter rechnen trotzdem nicht damit
dass katar das austragungsrecht entzogen
wird er wird das land hohen
schadensersatz zahlen müssen
und jetzt harter kontrast zum leben
gehörten eine durch und durch würde
volle veranstaltung in diesen zeiten gar
nicht so einfach
nämlich eine uni abschlussfeier in japan
der höhepunkt jeder bekommt sein diplom
fast persönlich trotz corona die
studenten sitzen zwar zuhause steuern
aber ihre eigenen telepräsenz roboter
und sehen quasi durch deren augen wie
ihnen die urkunde kein frei überreicht
wird
alles natürlich mit robe hut und
standesgemäße erinnerungsfoto man muss
ideen haben
das wetter bleibt herrlich sonnig und
warum die details hat gleich katja
hornuf claus kleber freut sich auf sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
wir danken für ihr interesse und ihrem
zuspruch wünschen ihnen alles gute und
sind morgen wieder darin sehen auch
wieder sehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das war nur ein
ganz ganz schmales wolkenband heute
diese kaltfront hier kaum zu erkennen
auf dem satelliten film brachte ein
wenig regen mit vor allen dingen in der
nacht mal auf norderney oder auf
helgoland jetzt dabei ist hoch loris
herangekommen hat viel sonnenschein
mitgebracht und die temperaturen in
richtung 25 grad getrieben damit war das
der erste offizielle meteorologische
sommer tag und auch in der nacht bleibt
es mild hier im westen liegen die
temperaturen bei 10 bis 7 grad kälter
wird es im süden und dem osten besonders
hier in der uckermark da sinken die
werte auf 1 grad da droht also in jedem
fall bot frost und dazu ist der himmel
meistens klar höchstens im nordwesten
gibt es ein paar kleine wolkenfelder und
auch morgen gibt es höchstens in
norddeutschland mal ein paar wolken
sonst aber strahlenden sonnenschein
der wind dreht allmählich von südost auf
südwest und damit wird es an der
nordseeküste etwas milder
morgen erwarten uns die
höchsttemperaturen von 18 19 grad sonst
sind es im binnenland zwischen 20 und 25
grad und nur an der ostsee bleibt es
hier mit 15 grad etwas kühler
ja es gibt doch schönes wetter auch in
den nächsten tagen höchstens hier in den
mittelgebirgen kann es mal einen kleinen
regenschauer geben im südwesten steigen
die temperaturen bis 26 grad
schönen abend noch